Ideas where nothing with that an idea.
So I say that a desire for an idea is
like a bait on a hook and you're
desiring an idea and you have to have
patients just like you do in fishing.
How deep that hook goes depends on the
size of that ball of consciousness and
designer.
Another word for it is like focus,
just focus on some and it's a little bit
like daydreaming spots come and Fox
common stocks come and meet me.
Boom.
An idea of condoms that is so thrilling.
You've caught a little purple fish with
red fins and and little little dancing,
speckled eyes and this little fish could
be just a fragment,
but you love this fragment.
You love this fish and that idea,
you write it down so you won't forget
it.
Then now that you have that fish even
more powerful bait and soon others will
swim in and join to it and the thing
will start emerging and it goes like
that for me anyway,
fragments,
but it's all ideas coming,
ideas that I've fallen in love with and
I'm an a fallen in love with different
ideas.
Then you will,
but there's billions,
trillions of ideas coming,
ideas for everything.
So that's how it,
that's how it goes.
Then you get the ideas organized and
then you translate those ideas and along
the way you stay open because the thing
isn't finished til it's finished.
There can be happy accidents.
You say,
how did I get so lucky to get this
thing?
I thought this was complete,
but this is beyond the beyond fitting in
here and jumping it.
Stay on your toes and don't walk away
from any element until it feels correct
because it's built out of many,
many,
many elements.
Stay true to the idea all along the
road,
and then you have some hope of the whole
working.